teens from around Nevada spent their
Saturday in North Las Vegas for a
science competition it was the first
time they've met in three years due to
the pandemic the event is meant to boost
interest and diversity in the fields
Joshua peguero reports from the Nevada
science pool
they were up early Saturday ready to be
quizzed on math and science no this
isn't your typical Jeopardy or game show
a lot of the teams they have lots of
expertise in their own Fields like that
question is the based on specific
subjects like physics biology chemistry
these students are from Palo Verde High
School in Summerlin I personally always
love the medical field I really like
explaining more about the human anatomy
the bodies how our minds break because
we're all so unique but yet we all share
the same body the winner of this
competition will have the opportunity to
compete in April in Washington DC where
there will be students from all around
the country the U.S department of energy
began the National Science Bowl in 1991
to encourage students to pursue careers
in science technology engineering and
math also known as stem smaller bowls
are held nationwide with teams made up
of four students one alternate and a
teacher coach Andrea just took McKinney
is one of the coaches in the valley I
come from the stem field I used to work
in cancer research and stuff and so I
try to use my personal background
um to help encourage them and you know
my time in Industry to say hey we need a
lot more individuals in stem especially
females data shows women blacks and
Hispanics are underrepresented in the
stem Workforce getting students involved
in these areas early on is really
important and you know what you're
seeing is kind of a culmination because
this starts with the parents and it
starts with the teachers and the younger
grades with early involvement however
there's hope it could improve diversity
in stem Joshua peguero eight news now
today's winning team was Davidson
Academy in Reno they won first and
second place Clark High School came in
third Davidson will now advance to the
National Science Bowl which takes place
on April 27th